for some people New Year's Eve is a
night to dress to the nines in England
there's one street that's synonymous
with clothing at its finest famed Savile
Row is home to centuries-old tailor
shops known for handcrafted bespoke
suits and other fine apparel now some of
these establishments are finding new
ways to attract new generations of
customers including Huntsman a shop we
had a chance to visit
it's amazing how much it's changed here
oh yeah yeah
welcome to Huntsman Jeff it's great to
be here yeah inside 11
SLO the patterns of famous clients past
and presence are unmistakable Lawrence
Olivier Eric Clapton David Bowie these
were based off of Gregory pecks that's
probably our most iconic Tweed I could
never be that bold wearing that but a
house draped in nearly 175 years of
tradition knows change is still
necessary Taj full took over at Huntsman
in 2019. how does someone become
managing director at Huntsman
being able to keep up with the times
heintzman sits on a narrow Street in
London that was first occupied mostly by
Military Officers in the late 1840s the
first tailor shops opened here
specializing in bespoke clothing cut and
made by hand for kings and queens world
leaders and Barons of business
through Wars and pandemics Savile Row
has endured but the last couple years
have been among the most consequential
let me take a closer look at the
shoulder during the pandemic Huntsman
pioneered the teleporting bespoke
experience using 4K cameras and robots
not unlike at hospitals you can do
surgery remotely so let's speak to the
companies who do this so we spoke to a
couple of Surgeons we spoke to a couple
of companies and then we came up with
our robot that works for us now within
seven cities in Asia on a full-time
basis I can actually assure you here
I've got the bunch in front of me um
what about this a lovely tan Barleycorn
do you think the robot fitting is just
as good as well yeah with that because
there's no actual element where the
robot is using an AI or an algorithm it
is the cutter looking taking pictures
and watching the fitting process Cutters
create the template or pattern on which
all future garments for a customer will
be based so four panels on a trouser two
the two the same in the front two at the
back
jacket two front two side two back uh
two top sleeve two honestly Max
Whittaker gave us a brief demonstration
how's that very good very good yeah the
first time yeah very good yeah I've seen
a lot worse okay good there are usually
three fittings involved in a bespoke
suit a process that typically takes two
and a half months to complete and starts
around eight thousand dollars per suit
everything is done on site including the
code making led by Steve Van who's going
into his 30th year including his
apprenticeship how long was the
apprenticeship mom still going on still
going on my apprenticeship there's not a
dive that goes by that I don't learn
something new think about something in a
different way everyone here has their
job
yes everyone knows their own skill sets
yeah so you either go I mean in this
room we're all coat makers
um in the other side of the room you've
got trouser makers so it's a very
individual and then you have waistcoat
makers as well and then obviously you've
got the Cutters upstairs who make the
patterns what part of the process are we
in now we've got to the stage of the
sleeves to go in so we've measured the
armo and now we've got to decide the
shape of the sleeve to match up with the
armhole
Steve I'd like to remind you before this
started you told me you were
uncomfortable on camera yeah
and you
now beautifully explain the process
uninterrupted so congratulations thank
you very much I mean I've been doing it
a good few years yeah I should be able
to talk about it you can make anything
work if you feel the right way in it
exactly Susan Bender is a contributing
editor at British Vogue who now also
works with Huntsman I think when I first
came here I was quite terrified
um it became like Huntsman the Bastion
of Savile bespoke tailoring but once you
actually come in here it's
very relaxed and there's nothing to be
terrified of I have to tell you I didn't
expect to see someone in denim
[Laughter]
at Huntsman
Freedom that
um bespoke Tyran can give to you they
can make you a denim suit if you want
that would be a real Canadian tuxedo
definitely
Bender has introduced a new look for the
modern hunts woman the ideas is like
it's like replaceable Parts yes so you
can design whatever you want so that
the jacket is constantly being used but
in different ways so you can add lapel
on to a jacket
it's
great perfect for travel one jacket five
six seven looks if not more how long
should a really well made bespoke
garment last for
60 to 100 years if not longer
the tailors on Saddle row believe
bespoke is a lifetime commitment and
Beyond at Huntsman the patterns of
customers who passed away hang from the
ceiling as the business welcomes in new
customers many of whom had their
curiosity peaked by the kingsman movie
come on in
the most visited room in the building in
the film this fitting room is
transformed into a secret entrance to a
clandestine world of Espionage and
Intrigue since 1849 Kingsman Taylor's
clothed the world's most powerful
individuals today's visitor could be
tomorrow's customer so if we have a 12
year old customer who walks through the
door who's a Kingsman fan they're
treated the same way as if they're
buying a bespoke garment from start to
finish
because times may change
but Excellence will always be in fashion
this is something that you think fathers
can hand down to sons and then to
grandsons and mothers to daughters and
Beyonds without a question of that it's
something I'm looking forward to do with
my son and for me that is incredible
like there's so many things that you can
hand down watches and whatnot but being
able to wear something knowing that your
father or mother had worn it previously
is also just as fulfilling
it is amazing watching the kids the
teenagers line up outside Huntsman oh
yeah because of the movie Patty you want
to picture your was that your son he had
the Epic the famous outfit oh yeah the
orange the orange one you were talking
about it with the Opera bringing it to a
new generations yeah kind of thing but I
have to ask a question I still don't get
what bespoke means well it's custom it's
custom made to you it's a bespoke suit I
love that bespoke I think you could have
bespoke anything so you better not gain
weight that's exactly it stop eating
that bush Noel the other great thing
about it is that it's lifetime
adjustments so you can well you can only
let it out so far lose weight gain
weight no they put a lot extra in there
they really do well for 20 grand they
better